يعد هذا الفيديو اجابه طال انتظارها عن
السؤال كيف ستطلق القوات الاوكرانيه
صواريخ ريمسترون قبل ايام قليله فقط كان
هناك اول دليل على ان الاوكرانيون
يستخدمون بالفعل بينستون لتدمير الاصول
العسكري الروسيه ولكن الصاروخ مصمم
لاطلاقه من الجو وجرى تحسين هذا الصاروخ
ايضا من قبل مختصين بريطانيين لاطلاقه
ارضيه
صممت هذه الصواريخ شركه تصنيع سلاح تشترك
فيها دول اوروبيه
باللغه العربيه
اساسا لتكون مضاده للدروع ومع الوقت تطورت
لتستطيع تدمير تشكيله واسعه من الاهداف
يذكره
هو عباره عن صاروخ جو ارض يحلقوا الى
مسافه 60 كم عند اطلاقه من الطائره اما في
حال اطلاقه من منصه دريه فلا يتجاوز مدى
عمله اثنا عشر كيلومترا يبلغ وزن الراس
الحربي سته كيلو غرامات 3600 غرام ودخل
الخدمه في يوليو 2016
ويكلف كل صاروخ الحكومه البريطانيه 2007
الاف دولار بينما لم تذكر لندن عدد
الصواريخ التي سترسلها الى الجيش
الاوكراني